in a column for the sun said that Donald
Trump is more popular than ever and
likened his comeback to that of Frank
Sinatra citing Trump's resilience and
humor as two major factors in his re uh
Resurgence here anyway joining us now to
explain all of this the host of
uncensored with Piers Morgan there's no
such thing as a censored Piers Morgan we
should say this before at the outset
here the morning you walked off the set
of the number one morning show in Great
Britain I wrote you I said whatever you
do don't quit and uh I don't know if I
don't know if that message got to you or
not but no it did but you know what you
know what Sean they said to me if you
apologize to Mega marle for disbelieving
her then you can keep your job the
problem but the problem was it would be
like saying you apologizing to Pinocchio
for believing Bia so I decided on
balance better to walk you know it's
funny because you know liberal Joe as I
call him uh Scarboro I mean he he used
to claim he's a conservative and it's
like you know he pretend he just he just
has adopted this liberalism because he
wants to be on television he used to beg
you know people here to please hire him
and he didn't like the place he was
working at so he figured well he's not
going to get hired here might as well do
that let's um let's talk about what you
see about Trump you'd been critical of
President Trump um I thought the speech
he gave in I was was gracious I thought
my last town hall with him uh very
measured smart funny a I'm we're seeing
a little bit different side of him not
talking as much about 2020 anymore and
he's looking forward I think it's
helpful well Hallelujah to that last
point because when I last interviewed uh
president Trump I did say to him look I
just think you got to move on from
looking back to 2020 all the time you
got to present a vision for America
going forward for 2024 and you can get
reelected and I noticed that he's now
stopped talking nearly so much about
2020 he's talking about 2024 and he's
showing all the best sides of Donald
Trump which you and I have always known
have been there he's shown the charm
he's shown the incredible resilience he
really is The Comeback Kid I would have
said a year ago there was no chance he
would have done what he did in Iowa he
also is showing that humor which seems
to upset all the right people you know I
thought that hilarious line he did in
Iowa when he said you know even if it
kills you basically your vote will count
the people taking that seriously are
exactly the kind of people I he was even
half laughing when he said it of course
of course it was a joke so I think you
put it all together look Donald Trump is
not an angel but nor is he a devil and
I've always respected his remarkable
ability to withstand the kind of
pressure that would knock off any other
public figure I know you know I remember
talking to him many years ago about what
happened in the uh financial crash of
the the mid90s when all his friends went
under pretty much and I said how did you
manage to keep going and he said you
know what I just had to not do what they
were doing which was running home to
Mommy and crying and saying isn't life
unfair I dug down I move forward and I
carry through the storm and I remember
that and I've watched him do it again
this year when as charge after charge
after charge has come at him uh he has
got stronger and the polling for him has
improved because even Republicans that
don't really like Donald Trump can see
that there is a Witch Hunt element to
all this that the the Democrats are
trying to kill him off but by doing so
they're making him more popular and
Donald Trump can feel that and I watched
him last night with you Sean and I
thought I see a guy right on top of his
game absolutely determined to get back
to the White House I think he's pretty
much got my nomination in the bag I
think he's going to win in New Hampshire
and South Carolina quite comfortably I
think this is all over probably before
super Tuesday
and then honestly who would put money
right now on Donald Trump not beating
Joe Biden when Joe Biden can barely
string a sentence together and could
barely stand on his own two feet if it
is Joe Biden you you said something that
is key and this is unique for both of us
is I've known Donald Trump almost 30
years long before he ever contemplated a
run for the presidency or getting
involved in politics in real life he is
one of the funniest people you'll ever
meet one of the most generous
uh
gregarious um friendly uh warm even um
and interesting people you'll ever meet
and loyal and loyal and extremely loyal
and he's like you like that so when I
left CNN for example you messaged me and
Donald Trump rang me and wrote To Me
numerous times in the next few months
and I never forgot that and you know and
you're the same and I think that loyalty
is a big trump card for him now you know
like I say he's not perfect there are
many things I've disagree with Donald
Trump about and I've gone toe-to-toe
with him about a few big issues so I'm
not going to pretend for a moment that I
think everything he does is right but I
do think J JP Morgan boss Jamie Diamond
got it right when he said if you try and
demonize everyone that is currently
voting for Donald Trump a you're
demonizing maybe 100 million Americans
but secondly you don't understand why
they're voting for him last election was
a basically a referendum on Trump who
had had a year of a p a global pandemic
with all the catastrophic Fallout and
Biden was able to hide in his bunker and
exploit that and and run as an
anti-trump candidate this time round if
it is Trump Biden it will be a
referendum on Joe Biden's presidency
which judging by his current approval
ratings is incredibly unpopular with the
American public very very different
battle and he doesn't have to change who
he is that's the interesting part of
this let Trump be Trump and he is a
fighter but Americans kind of need a
fighter right now the world stage needs
an American leader uh we see what's
happening in Europe we see what's
happening in the Middle East uh but the
side of Donald Trump that we know that
maybe it doesn't show as often I think
it's to his benefit to also show that
time and it's sincere it's not contrived
I think he's taking advice from you and
other people and I think he's got to
Pivot no he doesn't listen to me well I
think he I think he does actually uh
more than probably that you get credit
for but I do think that and I you know
he's frustrating Donald Trump because
people who like him and I've known him a
long time and he's been very good to me
people who like him are frustrated by
him because occasionally he will just do
stuff when he go come on don't do that
um and I think I noticed that speech at
IA was very gracious very warm and when
he talks about being inclusive if he
means that my God America needs to come
together again number one superpower in
the world but so fractured and divided
if Donald Trump Mark 2 back in the White
House can be a force for Unity I'm all
for it let me tell you the world W since
Joe Biden's been president abdicating
its role in the world stage has not been
good for anybody um and his policies
worked it's really that simple so uh
Pierce great to see you I I miss hanging
out with you my friend and hopefully see
you soon thank you I would love that hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else